i don't want to bring up any weird stuff
but i do watch it all the time and
brendan was just on with bobby lee yeah
is that something you're talking about
these days i'm i'm i love that guy okay
but i've been friends of mine before
ever i yeah i spoke to him in a way that
was inappropriate i was mad about
something i was given information should
have waited on more information i should
have given him the benefit out because
he didn't know what the hell was going
on and i and i called him up and i i own
my mistakes i love that about you
because you're like this is on me it is
this is on i didn't know anything i
couldn't see what happened we patrick
has no clue about this well i'll tell
you i'll fair but yeah but but it's fine
but but um i love that guy yeah and and
i've known him forever and i called him
up and i go i apolo he was mad he read
me the riot act and i was like you're
right when you're right you're right but
when you screw up and and you you
you get angry and you don't give you're
a friend of yours like that the benefit
of the doubt you deserve a little heat
and and but i respect you brian it takes
a lot which i love you for this to
because nobody does this [ __ ] nobody i
own my mistakes
i did it because guess what i've been
angry angry and in that moment yeah bad
information whatever right i've done
[ __ ] to where if it was the other way i
would have punched me and i was given
information that that was i should have
waited and i should have and i
when you have a friend who when you have
somebody who i like as much as bobby
yeah who didn't deserve you got to be
able to say you got to ask him you got
to go hey you know explain to me and and
i and i was outside of myself wasn't who
i am made a mistake you're human you're
like he accepted my apology i i
apologize we're good man it's all it's
great but you know what's the big lesson
you learned through all this whether
it's bobby or ricky or who doesn't
what's the lesson you'll learn don't
assume give your friends the benefit of
the doubt and you know make sure you got
all your information in your ducks in a
row and even when you do
ask for first don't you know go and say
what's going on
i i it's not like me it was uh there
were a lot of extenuating factors i was
given a lot of information i was
defending a friend
you know brendan's life brennan's my
brother man so so i i i'm very
protective of my friends i'm very loyal
yeah but i should have realized i was
also talking to a friend somebody i love
very much
bobby for how many years 25 years great
longer than brenda but he's also he's
also a great dude yeah bobby's hilarious
too yeah well you guys did mad tv
together well we were on i wasn't on the
same thing but i've known him forever
and i've always had nothing but great
love and effect and his girl kalila she
sees i don't know her i don't know you
don't even know her at all i don't know
her bobby seems very level-headed though
oh yeah i i don't look i don't have any
beef with that that's not that's
something that uh was unfortunate it was
one phone call
and uh and i apologized right away yeah
i respect that you own that yeah you
gotta own you were very clear this is on
me yes ma'am that's a you gotta own you
gotta i got it i gotta so if you like
this clip and you wanna watch another
one click right here and if you wanna
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you